welcome back boys and girls to new
rockstars my name is Sam bash and today
I'm gonna be talking about the flash big
surprise specifically episode 403 luck
be a lady what a delightfully goofy and
fun episode huh let's get going here's
your spoiler warning for the flash TV
show past present and future episodes
that comics and you know everything else
as you know I like to do a top 10 list
of the miserable details so starting
with number 10 Becky sharp aka hazard
our monster of the week if you will
Hazzard made her debut in infinity Inc
back in January 1987 she's always been
kind of evil but not too important to
the comics but I do love how the show
was able to utilize her and her
abilities especially love how we got the
comic accurate Hazzard costume in the
beginning of this episode
remember that outfit she's wearing when
she's got this to dice on her vest thing
and she's working at the casino as her
like outfit and she hops on the bus
there it is in all its glory
now usually Hazzard uses a pair of dice
to affect probability in her favor
giving her a good look but that's all we
really know about her character we do
get a kami of those dice if you pass
forward to the climax of the episode
when Hazzard is racking up the millions
in the casino oh that's right with a
pair of dice very cool speakin of
casinos our number 9 slot on the list
goes to hazards place of employment take
a look at that enormous signage behind
Hazzard when she notices that her car
has been booted once again notice that
names star-like well to be fair
starlight is the name of a casino in
Vancouver where they film this show but
because DC Warner Brothers most likely
left the name in there for a reason as
you know these shows love to hide names
of come up with creators and little nods
to other comfor characters my nerdy gut
so telling me that this is a little not
a certain member of the Superman family
now if you're familiar with the
character steel no not steel or citizen
steel a commander steel whatever his
name is from legends of tomorrow but
John Henry iron steel one that Shaq
played in that movie then you might be
familiar with a nice Natasha
irons she's always been kind of all over
the place with her superhero identity
but most famously she's gone by
starlight let's move on to number eight
when hazard hops on that fateful bus
that grants her probability altering
abilities we actually get some major
hints to the future of this season dirt
team flash makes this same discovery
during the episode but there's more to
it than that pay attention to the
details Kilgore he's sitting on the bus
working on his computer and once that
Speed Force portal opens up he somehow
gets fused with part of his computer
Becky sharp she's feeling unlucky or
maybe because she's wearing dice on her
now she can alter probability no no
there's a lot of who in these sentences
has it doesn't make sense but we still
love it but here's where things get
interesting notice the other two
passengers we see on the bus neither of
them have really been advertised by the
CW but obviously we now know that they
most likely have some sort of metahuman
ability as for the woman played by
actress Chelsea Kurtz I'll be honest
there's not too much to pull from here
she doesn't really do or have anything
on her that gives us a clue as to her
newfound abilities but notice the sad
emic sad face sitting near the back of
the bus a little digging tell us that
this actor's name is not Afonso and on
IMDB he's been given the codename Reaper
so I'm guessing once the dark matter
hit him his sadness is now his power I'm
just guessing here but also this does
raise some questions the weeper is a
costume villain from the comics leapers
main identity is mortimer gloom because
of course and he doesn't actually have
any discernible abilities more deburr
just usually writes letters to family
saying that they lost a loved one or
something else that's depressing and
when they leave their house he robs them
it's super weird and honestly he hasn't
really been in the comics since the 70s
and that was just one appearance but he
did team-up with the Joker in the Batman
braving the bolt animated series so
there you go moving on to number seven
something worth mentioning the break-up
box which is amazing by the way is made
of a special material anybody catch that
oh that's right Atlanta plastic Wow of
course most of you know that our Justice
League member Aquaman is the King around
those parts but on earth to Atlantis is
a little bit different if you remember
in episode 207 guerrilla warfare Harry
brings up a map of earth - in Atlantis
is actually above ground whoa and it's a
popular tourist attraction based on
Barry's phone call with his other
worldly mother an episode of 2:13
welcome to earth - next up number six
notice the name of the bank that iris
mentions after Harry puffs onto earth
one O'Sullivan's bank sure this could
just be you know a fun name of a bank
it's fun to say but since we're on the
CW I think this is a nod to one of my
favorite supporting Superman characters
Chloe Sullivan I think the Smallville
reference actually I'm almost like 95%
sure it's a Smallville reference you
guys don't know she was Clark's best
friend on Smallville that helped him you
know set up a watchtower solve crimes
you name it she did it now number five
on the list let's look at that size
with Joe in cecile working on his house
what was that align the Joe dropped when
he was speaking with the plumber you
know this house is if you're
keeping up with these videos and the
show you should know that there's a line
that was translated from Barry's
speedforce language after he popped out
of the speedforce now here's the
question did Joe mention this line
because he had heard it from Barry and
Cisco when they translated it and he
just wanted to make a joke or did he say
it because he doesn't want to leave his
house and it's he's a little sensitive
people poking fun at it some of you
might you know come to a conclusion
really fast but I'm asking this because
what Barry is spouting out nonsense in
the premiere episode of the season he
mentions something that could be
verified as a premonition later in this
episode
remember our episode cliffhanger Joe's
have another baby I will get to that
later on because I have some theories
but remember Barry mentions diapers and
he smiles now I originally thought this
could be you know a nod to Barry and
iris as kids Darland on the tornado
twins but maybe he's only seeing a
season's worth of future events I mean
oh your theories down below number four
what was that city that Barry ran to
when he was all naked and covered in
Speed Force Lightning oh yeah Ivy City
that certainly sounds familiar oh yes
because it sounds like Ivy town which is
a place that exists in the arrowverse
and in the comics speaking of comic book
goodies during the scene between Cisco
and Harry when they mentioned Jesse
getting our own team Cisco throw is that
a couple of names now none of these
names mean anything to DC Comics
although some spongebob fans may be
familiar with the quickster love that
however I think this might be a nod to
Jesse quicks company from the comics
quickstart enterprises that's number
three famous in the comics Jesse quick
runs her father Johnny quicks company
quickstart enterprises which is a
multimedia company but maybe now she
runs earth to STAR Labs has renamed it
quickstart enterprises I mean I'm not
really hung up if it is a multimedia
company or like a tech company it could
be anything as long as we get the name
I'll be happy who knows if we will even
get the name but we do know that jetski
broke while he's part and now he's
running away to our number two on the
list Blue Valley Blue Valley in the
comics is actually the real home of
Wally West yay he grew up there he made
the flash fan club there and eventually
he returns there in the future to raise
his family with Linda Park
mmm sad they didn't really get together
in the show it's roughly in Nebraska
which isn't too far from Central City
which is supposed to be kind of in
Missouri so Wally isn't too far from the
action hopefully we'll see him join up
with the Titans on their new show on the
DCF it'd be a fun time here's hoping but
he better be there for Barry and irises
wedding he better be there for the
crossover and he better be there for the
birth of his new brother / sister
perfect segue into our number one slot
Joe and Cecile are having a baby oh my
goodness Jay now two things came to my
mind one this could be a way for Joe to
leave the show there's a tear you could
make the decision that Central City is
too dangerous for a baby now with all
the meadows and he could move away
however with him and Cecile deciding not
to move at the end of the episode I'm
not sure that's the case and to my brain
is freaking out over who this baby could
be who's that baby here my theories
number again number one this could be
the introduction of another flash
villain hear me out in the new 52 iris
and Barry aren't adoptive siblings and
iris actually has a brother named Daniel
Daniel through some comic book
gobbledygook turned out to be the new
reverse flash or a reverse flash there's
a couple I guess he's the one covered in
metal that you guys have probably seen
when you google reverse flash he looks
very cool looks like a monster now I
think we've had enough evil speedsters
and the character isn't that important
in the comics so I'm not sure it'll be
him but it could be my number two option
and this one's kind of out there but
just listen I think it could be dawn and
dawn I know Barry's kids that I
mentioned earlier no I don't actually
mean these are like Barry's actual kids
but they could use this pregnancy as a
way to introduce dawn and Dawn to the
show then we get a time travel story
where we meet and dawn and Dawn in the
future all grown up which would give us
the introduction of trouble please Bart
Allen aka impulse because that's the
character we actually want on the show
really really bad my crazy theories
aside what do you guys think who could
this baby be let me know down below but
really quick a few honorable mentions
just need to mention the wexel couple
mentioned by iris could be a nod to
elmer wexel creator of Miss America of
the Justice Society who we've seen on
legends of tomorrow
Algernon Arcade supplies could be a nod
to flowers for algernon or it could be a
nod to the long-forgotten character
chess man aka Algernon Blackwood from
Earth Fox notice iris and Barry's
wedding getup looks an awful lot like
the drawing we got for the crisis on
Earth X promo the mega crossover this
year the pilot on the polina I'm
guessing is supposed to look a lot like
Captain slowly the man who landed the
plane on the Hudson River also the
reaction super weird when the plane
extinguishes its own fires and lastly
from Twitter actually at bohemian Barry
mentioned that the thinker's headpiece
looks an awful lot like the brain the
infamous Teen Titans Vil and I thought
that was cute anyways that's it for me
thank you guys so much for watching be
sure to like this video if you liked it
make sure you subscribe for more
breakdowns especially our Game of
Thrones stranger things but also make
sure you check out need-to-know speaking
a need-to-know this Friday we're holding
a costume slash cosplay contest all you
guys got to do is put together a costume
or cosplay from one of your favorite TV
shows or movies can go ahead and
download that stardust app make it star
dust post tagging new rock stars and we
will feature you guys on our show
need-to-know and the top three people we
choose will get prizes whoa and the top
prize will get a hundred our gift card
to the movies oh my good many things all
you guys got to do is upload that post
before Friday tomorrow at 8 a.m. PST get
on it as quick as you can again tweet me
your thoughts and feelings on this
episode at Sam badger on Twitter I'll
see you guys next time